bonjour didier mérigou merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors je
viens de le dire à près de 90% du
personnel soignant été vaccinées au 31
août dernier pourquoi vous demander tout
simplement un délai au delà du 15
septembre prévu
laurent demande élevée parce que le
gouvernement a annoncé de manière un
petit peu rapide de l'obligation
vaccinale est un certain nombre d'agents
hospitaliers n'étant pas encore activé
le demandera ce qui est ce mois
supplémentaires que le gouvernement a
accordé dans les tomes parus égalité de
traitement des fonctionnaires mais aussi
pour permettre à ceux qui ne sont pas
encore affinés pour des raisons diverses
et variées à pouvoir rencontrer le
médecin du travail ou le service de
santé sécurité au travail pour qu' il
puisse être éclairé sur
les raisons de se faire vacciner ou
pourquoi ils pourraient eux aussi
apporté leur inquiétude et être
peut-être éclairer vous rassuré par le
médecin du travail sur leur situation
personnelle j'entends par là des
personnels qui ont des maladies auto
immunes qui ont des cancers qui sont en
situation particulière il ne faut pas
qu'ils trouvent les informations quant à
la vaccination sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense que c'est un médecin qui doit
être en phase 2 est donc le gouvernement
comme les choses sont fait un petit peu
dans la précipitation les avons orienté
pour certains vers les directeurs des
ressources humaines qui ne sont pas
médecins et nous nous estimons que ce
n'est pas correct par rapport aux agents
hospitaliers qui aujourd'hui que le
chant dans le doute et donc c'est bien à
des médecins qui doivent avoir à faire
de telle manière à ce qu'ils soient
éclairés de manière médical et qu'il
puisse exposer leurs soucis de santé
sans que quelque part il ne soit jugé
par rapport à leurs soucis de santé pour
cela c'est le médecin du travail on sait
aujourd'hui dans la fonction publique
hospitalière animaux que beaucoup plus
de médecins du travail et donc c'est
pour ça aussi que l'on demande à voir ce
délai supplémentaire pour pouvoir
permettre à l'ensemble des agents de
pouvoir avoir ce rendez vous donc quand
je parle de l'ensemble d argent je parle
bien sûr des non vaccinés et qu'est ce
que vous pourriez répond à ceux qui
pourraient vous dire éventuellement que
les professionnels de la santé avait
déjà de nombreux mois pour se faire
vacciner avant
je crois que les professionnels de santé
sont comme le restant des français ils
sont mitigées pour certains par rapport
au vaccin ils ont besoin d'être rassurés
ils ont besoin d'être informés ce n'est
pas parce qu'on travaille à l'hôpital
que quelque part voilà on connaît
peut-être forcément tous les processus
liés à la vaccination et puis je le
rappelle quand même voilà entre la 5g
qui était délivré par le vaccin et
toutes les propos qui ont été tenus par
les anti vhc par les complotistes voilà
ça a continué à peut-être
créer des doutes
peut-être pour certains agents ne
sachant plus quelle sur quel pied danser
voilà un sens dans la tente et donc
voilà nous on souhaite qu' il puisse y
avoir ce délai comme dans les dom
puisque dans les dom on a encore moins
le maxi dé la situation en france elle
n'est pas identique dans tous les
établissements même si on est à 80% maxi
d il ya les endroits où dans des maisons
de retraite par exemple les ehpad ou sur
trente agents les racistes qui sont pas
vaccinés si le 15 ces agents se
retrouvent suspendus sarr est
extrêmement compliqué à pouvoir faire
tourner les structures on ad'autres
également des dj bric si vous demandez
ce délai c'est aussi pour éviter que les
salariés soient déjà inquiété
premièrement mais aussi éviter que qu'il
y ait des dément qu'un dans les ehpad ou
à l'hôpital c'est bien ça totalement
nous on y est on a des remontées de
certains établissements où il y à de
nombreux agents qui refusent de se faire
vacciner pour des raisons x y ou z et
donc si les chefs d'établissement
applique la loi et c'est ce qu'ils vont
faire le case nous allons de retrouver
proche d'une situation de chaos dans
certains établissements moi j'ai déjà
des retours sur des réanimations qui
vont fermer sur des services des néo
donné aux lattes qui vont aussi fermé
donc moi je n'ai aucune envie que le
système de santé soit encore remis une
nouvelle fois à rude épreuve et je crois
que le gouvernement doit entendre notre
revendication pour pouvoir permettre
encore un certain nombre d'agents à
pouvoir se faire vacciner je vous donne
un exemple très concret aujourd'hui
quand on se fait vacciner on doit s'y un
parquet comme quoi on a le consentement
éclairé c'est à dire qu'on demande de
vaccins comment aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
alors que ce lac st obligatoire on peut
forcer les agents à signer un tel
document nous on a des agents qui se
sont rendus dans les centres de
vaccination on leur a demandé de signer
le pacte qu'ils ont refusé parce qu'ils
ont dit oui j'en vois pas pourquoi
excuses mais on doit demander le vaccin
puisqu'il est obligatoire moi j'étais la
demande très officielle au niveau du
ministère de la santé pour que les
agents aujourd'hui d'en cas de
l'obligation vaccinale n'est pas assigné
ce papier pour pouvoir se faire vacciner
parce que les agents estiment que c'est
pas à eux de signer un papier comme quoi
ils demandent le vaccin alors qu' il est
obligé il il est obligatoire de par la
loi donc nous sommes dans l'attenté
d'une instruction du ministère de telle
manière à ce que ces éléments soient
éclaircis parle pour les chefs
d'établissement et donc ce qui
permettrait encore un certain nombre
d'agents de pouvoir rentrer dans un
système de processus vaccinale avant le
15 mai pour cela maintenant il ya une
question de temps c'est pour ça qu'on
demande aussi d'avoir ce mois
supplémentaires didier mary très
rapidement parce qu'on a plus vraiment
le temps en temps quelques mots
seulement vous demandez donc un délai
d'un mois supplémentaire pour la
vaccination des soignants mais est ce
que je sais force ouvrière sentez vous
vous inciter à la vaccination
oui je crois qu'il faut et au mois je
déteste avoir langue de bois nous sommes
en situation pandémique est mort tous
les jours on n'a pas le droit de jouer
la vidéo avec la vie des idées de nos
concitoyens ni avec celle des soignants
bien sûr que nous le disons depuis le
début nous sommes pour la vaccination et
je le précise nous sommes bien pour
leurs accusations contre le colis c'est
la seule aujourd'hui qu'ils édictent
d'avoir des cas graves
saab est toute contamination donc c'est
un élément important nous n'avons rien
aujourd'hui qui est validée par les
scientifiques comme traitements qui
pourraient être administrés à la peur du
vaccin ou de manière prophylactique à la
place du vaccin donc bien sûr que nous
soutenons le fait que les agents soient
acquittés après nous sommes contre le
fait que on se retrouve à l'hôpital avec
des agents qui vont avoir des sanctions
parce qu'ils refusent de s'enraciner il
faut de la pédagogie et il faut les
amener à se faire vacciner c'est à dire
les rassurer pour qu'ils puissent faire
ce choix rassurée donc les soigne on a
bien compris votre
de vue merci beaucoup didier be rich
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur un
très franc je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat force
ouvrière santé merci beaucoup